yeah brian those fireworks are still  going off behind me you could probably  even hear some in the distance now those  backyard fireworks cause major concern  for fires and earlier today this palm  tree right behind me here had to pay the  price for it  take a look at this video you can  clearly see fireworks shooting up in the  air and then one gets caught onto the  palm tree firefighters responded and  quickly put it out earlier my  photographer and i were driving around  in the southwest part of the valley  there were tons of backyard fireworks  happening happening all around us many  neighborhoods even having their own  watch party fines are pretty hefty if  you are caught with illegal fireworks  you could be fined up to 10 thousand  dollars reporting live tonight victoria  saha live local now